Aww Yeah! Today you will learn English
with Harry Potter and the magical sport
of the Wizarding World, Quidditch.
And, if you're new here every single week
we make fun lessons just like this one
so that you can learn to understand
fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Krishna says that he feels like he's finally learning the English that natives really speak.
And you will too —
all you have to do is hit that subscribe button,
and the bell down below so you don't
miss any of our new lessons.
Hey! Do you want to learn the vocabulary
that you actually need to understand
natives and communicate confidently?
Well, we have a really fun way for you to get it
with our Fluent with Friends course.
In this 48-week course, you will learn
thousands of words and expressions
that natives actually use in everyday conversation,
alongside the first two seasons
of the TV series Friends,
with 20+ page PDF Power Lessons,
vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle global community,
and so much more.
And you can try it for FREE right now
with our 3-part Masterclass.
Just click up here or down in the description below
to learn more and sign up.
Hey muggle! We will make gaining English
fluency like magic for you,
with all of our lessons
featuring Harry Potter in this playlist.
I highly recommend that you
check that out after you finish this video
by clicking up here or down in the description below.
Hey! Thanks so much for joining me today.
Keep going on your journey to English fluency
with our Harry Potter playlist.
And, now it's time to go beyond the classroom
and LIVE your English!
Aww Yeah!